all right did the military make friends
with Little Green Men lawmakers are
taking the Pentagon to task for
allegedly covering up information on
UFOs starting next week representative
Anna Paulina Luna
I love saying her name Anna Paulina Luna
[Laughter]
[Music]
Luna
okay
[Music]
she's going to chair congress's next
round of UFO hearings featuring
whistleblower David grush now that's a
bad name you can't sing David grush
but yet he's another whistleblower I'm
hearing more whistleblowing at Congress
than when I walk through Times Square in
a speedo
hahaha
yeah grush is the former Intel officer
who last month claimed the Pentagon was
hiding a top secret alien program
complete with non-human vehicles and
even bodies he even says they're hiding
info about Adam schiff's home planet
the allegations have also renewed
interest in the pentagon's real UFO
Department the newly created all domain
anomaly resolution office or
has been tasked with identifying and
tracking mysterious objects that could
pose a risk to National Security unless
of course it's White House cocaine
yeah they recently said one of their top
concerns is intelligent or
extraterrestrial technical surprise so
not only might aliens exist but they
might be smarter and better equipped
which wouldn't be tough have you seen
earthlings lately
yeah
meantime Chuck Schumer introduced an
amendment to declassify all government
data on UFOs in it he repeatedly used
the term non-human which if you think
about it he could have been talking
about his hair plugs
it's not really hair plugs anyway but
once uh but once what but what once
would have gotten you laughed out of
Washington has now become a serious
discussion but if everyone is so
concerned about aliens then where the
hell are they they could be hiding in
plain sight seriously has anyone checked
Gerald nodler's pants
[Applause]
uh Julie um the good thing about the
discovery of aliens for you is that it
will why did the dating pool oh my God
yeah you you don't know if you're tired
of men and you're not into women aliens
could have a third gender a real one
real biological identity that you could
attach yourself to thank you so much for
that advice yes I hadn't thought of that
angle do you believe the Pentagon is
hiding this wonderful thing from you
specifically I'm so glad you asked
um so Congressional investigations are
apparently going on right now as we
speak in secret in secret which has me
leaves me confused and don't understand
it it doesn't make sense it's not like
the White House is trying to hide it
right yeah they let Kamal Harris out in
public every day yes they even let her
speak I wouldn't be surprised if she
commutes to work in a UFO
which would explain the cocaine that was
you know found in the white house
entrance where she they could blame it
on the aliens it wasn't Hunter yeah it
wasn't common it was the aliens well
when Hunter's gun was lost Hunter blamed
illegal aliens remember that he told the
police he said uh I think those guys
might be illegals Michael how can they
were talking about technical Supremacy
but how can alien life forms be a match
for our unbeatable strength of our
diversity
that's a great point because it's gonna
the next war is going to be a diversity
War it is going to be diversity work I
don't care if you can go through
dimensions and faster than light yeah
yeah let's yeah I got four of these how
many do you have damn it it's like Uno
but for Galactic Supremacy
pick four uh I don't buy this for a
second I just think this is the Pentagon
looking for more money right they're
like oh these the guy they got these
aliens now I want to see proof this is
like uh when your local news station
they take the spark plug cap off a car
and then they take it to a mechanic and
the mechanic's like oh you need a whole
new engine here I call
if there's alien ships I want to see
them because the the Pentagon really
can't be trusted yeah they can't buy
them a bunch of new toys they leave them
lying around everywhere that's right
left a bunch of stuff in Afghanistan and
they're like oh oopsie Daisy we gotta
replace that then we send a bunch of
stuff over to the Ukraine it's insane I
say show me the alien ships or you get
nothing Pentagon people I wish it worked
that way they're still going to take
your money it's like it is it's like
three card Monty you can't win they're
gonna get it anyway look aliens under
there cat do you are you as cynical is
Mr Loftus
I don't like being compared to him
but I I hate to say this it pains me to
say this but I agree with Michael Loftus
thank you right my self-esteem meter
just refilled yeah because I think that
it's either the government's covering up
the alien thing or they want us to think
they're covering up the alien thing
because they're actually covering up
something else it's an attraction that
they're honest it's that they're always
lying even more than we think that
they're lying yeah exactly it could be
like actual military stuff we're
creating and we're saying these are
unidentified flying objects but we're
actually testing new stealth devices and
yeah stuff I also think aliens might
already be here though that's true and
you're sitting next to one
no I mean like I don't think we can see
them yeah it's true but they're already
around but they don't want to tell the
government they're here because you know
why we'll make them do paperwork that is
true cat cat
okay it's going to be a long segment
from Walter right here I know that's why
I saved you for last year first of all I
need I know the Whistleblower I know
Dave Grudge okay I can prove that after
the show with my text messages
um he is a kind of Boy Scout Hardy Boys
character who has discovered aliens in
his work for the government and is just
bound and determined to show us all the
truth he's actually a very sincere guy
is a mountain climber he lives in
Colorado so uh I wouldn't discount this
completely but I think we're entering a
very risky period obviously aliens don't
want us to know they're here right or
they would do stunts over the Empire
State Building
Etc
so we're in Congress going to out their
existence and they have Superior
Technologies isn't that dangerous
America though may get its wish it may
see a congressional hearing at which all
our big shots are there arranged behind
their desks with their glasses of ice
water and they out the existence of
aliens and suddenly a blue blue beam
comes into the room vaporizes Chuck
Schumer Etc
um
I didn't realize uh we had a we had a
pro vaporizing audience tonight
but but I'm gonna tell you really this
is deadly serious and whether you
believe it or not they want you to you
know it's interesting I always think
about aliens as like if we're the Ant
Hill that's like 500 feet from an
overpass right the animal the ant hill
has no idea that there's an overpass
there with cars going up and down I
think that's the way we are we're in
we're we're the ant hill and everything
else is so big and so vast that it's
unseeable they don't want to be famous
and we're going to make them famous and
they're going to stop on that ant hill
that's what I predict goodbye Capitol
Building I mean January 6th you've seen
nothing yet when the aliens do their
Insurrection well they just had those
aliens that landed in Vegas a couple
weeks ago so The Invasion should be a
lot a lot of them already come from
Vegas Yes Vegas is where the aliens have
been living for a long time you see them
at the blackjack tables yeah
um yeah I mean look at Carrot Top all
right
look at them I dare you I did once I was
waiting for a time he was in line in
front of me my eyes were burned for days
he's a good friend of mine yeah
okay I hate him up next national stories
make you want to snooze then stick
around for local news
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else